j'arrive en ont marre c'est tout voilà
il y a un an le jaune recouvrait la
france un mouvement d'une ampleur
inédite
mais le gilet jaune comme signe de
protestation ça ça n'était pas la
première fois les premiers enfilé le
jaune ce sont peut-être des belges en 97
venus défiler devant le siège de renault
contre la fermeture de l'usiné de
vilvorde par vraiment âge il est plutôt
une chasuble le gilet qu'on connaît
c'est le gouvernement qui l'a imposée
aux français en 2008
un kit comprenant un gilet fluo et un
triangle de pré signalisation sera
obligatoire l' obligation s'applique en
cas de panne ou d'accident
en complément des feux de détresse le
gilet doit être impérativement dans
l'habitacle ça y est le jaune est dans
la boîte à gants le ver est dans le
fruit
quelques mois plus tard en bretagne les
routes sont bloquées par les opposants à
l'écotaxe qui doit frapper les poids
lourds sur leur dos le fameux gilet aux
portes de la bretagne opération péage
gratuit et slogans clairement affichée
depuis hier la colère des bretons est
aussi froide que la météo
finalement ils opteront pour le bonnet
rouge mais un mois plus tard des
handicapés défilent en gilet jaune à
nantes
leur revendication des salaires décents
je viens avec 700 euros par mois donc
avec un loyer l'edf à toutes les
factures ne reste même pas 50 euros le
gilet devient un emblème de ralliement
comme en 2011 avec ses salariés victimes
de l'amiante en 2012 avec ses employés
en colère contre la fermeture de leur
usine ou toujours en 2012 des parents
d'élèves qui dénoncent la fermeture
d'une classe dans leur village l'un
d'eux aura une idée qui fera son show
ouvre ce matin pour faire connaître leur
lutte les parents sont passés à la
vitesse supérieure en déménageant bureau
et tableau noir sur ce rond-point de
dinan drôle d'endroit pour faire classe
2013 des salariés d'une usine en
redressement en fils le gilet jaune et
vont tracter où ça sur une barrière de
péage près d'aix en provence
mais c'est en 2014 que le gilet jaune se
fait un nom le nom de la colère celle
des parents d'élèves
encore heureux
opposés à la réforme des rythmes
scolaires des parents d'élèves en colère
qui descendent dans la rue aujourd'hui
et demain on les appelle les gilet jaune
ils viennent d'ailleurs de créer une
association alors à l'automne 2010 8
quand une mobilisation nationale se
prépare sur les réseaux sociaux
le gilet il trouve naturellement sa
place à tous un gilet jaune bagnols foot
et les en évidence sur le tableau de
bord toute la semaine la fin jusqu'au 17
la vidéo de cet internaute ghislain
coutard posté le 24 octobre 2018 sur
facebook sera vu plus de 5 millions de
fois le 17 novembre
ils sont des centaines de milliers à
défiler dans les rues de france au péage
sur les ronds-points anjou
[Musique]